did you have something you wanted to add
I forgot okay now you say you're not
gonna lie oh yeah yeah
I'm scared to get married why because um
The Generation Now compared to back in
the days I'm talking before we were born
it was different like back in the days
when when they meet each other they get
married and they just stay together you
know what I'm saying about a generation
now it's like it's bad it's toxic what I
mean by that is like everybody's just
breathing each other everybody's having
babies and then they never would that
same person do you get what I'm trying
to say and it's scary man I've seen it
so many times with a lot of people and
it affects me the reason why I say it
affects me because it's not free on the
child I don't know excuse me imagine
that you wanted to get married now
that's what I'm saying I've always said
like like say full song for me I have a
son
I tried so hard obviously to make the
relation work
yeah I'm not saying I'm perfect you know
what I'm saying but I was never
acquitted I see as like if you've made
her family just but like you gotta stick
together for life you know I mean but
our generation I think I blame the
social media I feel like it's that it's
a distraction this is my honest opinion
technology yeah but it's a technology so
that's why I'm scared to get me I'm
scared like if I get married after three
years hold on wait a minute oh she's
gonna wanna take my money or she wanna
take my house can I ask you a question
when was the last time you had sex
are you asking me yeah he's Jamaican
Nancy maybe like that I've got Jamaica
about fruit two days three days ago oh
are you serious about that person
no no because I'm asking that because
the way he's describing I'm tired of
people saying oh this is what I want and
his things have changed and they're
contributing to all we have to be that
what we want we have to be
accountability you can't turn around and
say this is what I want but what are you
doing to make that happen to make that
happen because the change don't come
from out there the change comes from you
within and if you want to see a change
then it's down to each individual to
start making the change you can't turn
around and say this is what I want I
don't want to be paddling in a muddy
pool when you're helping make the pool
muddy
because at the end of the day what have
you got to choose from
that you've really crept in
that's why I say self-love I hear that
answer but then but you get to ever have
to agree with the same thing even even
though you still love that person it's
just you know you need to be you know
you need to be you need to be more fussy
more selective and
treasure your dick self-love I'm not
gonna lie
as far as I'm concerned if you want
somebody good don't be dipping your dick
in somebody bad auntie I hear what
you're saying but for us men yeah and
I'm talking for us it's hard
you know safe sex jerk off then you're
not messing with nobody's mind you're
not messing with nobody's body there's
no chance that any contraception is
gonna fail and that you can preserve
yourself
you need to be more fussy that's the
right idea but I think I think from a
man to man right I think you focus that
energy imagine you're saving that energy
for like the one in it kill it with it
so but masturbation point I think is not
the way because
leads to leads to um oh man you're
leaving me hanging I was giving you spot
right now come on things and then it
leads to that lack of discipline but I
would say Focus that imagine you're
saving that energy for the one in it and
it makes you all the more intense
because when you meet that one you pull
out all the steps
I'm just going to give you little
devil's advocate here okay I don't think
your generation really understands this
okay for for men like women like guys
that sleep around and and treat like
women modern women don't like men that
treat them like queens and the problem
is like if if guys
aren't sleeping around they start to
like think too highly of each girl and
treat them too well and modern women
don't like that it's not like in your
generation where like a girl's courted
and like they respect it and they're
excited like you can just Court the nice
girl and she she wants you like for them
it's like basically if they give a girl
everything She Wants then she doesn't
like them and girls don't like guys that
don't sleep around like they only want
guys that sleep around
if that's the case and you've already
got a child
don't have number one get old woman I
hate our energy but then you get there's
some woman out there just just no I said
get an older woman an old mature woman
like the woman that he said that he
found one that's feminine she can't
breathe you've already got a son you
don't want no more children concentrate
on your one child have a happy
relationship with woman that can't
breathe
problems
[Laughter]
so my my what I think is it's modern
times cool for modern solutions in it
like that that free market of people
sleeping around with each other I think
that's always existed I think it's
always going to exist
um I think the fact that women value men
who are more experienced I think is a
sign of that just the selection in this
day game has gotten a lot tougher I
think that back in the day guys guys
would get with women just because
they're in the right place and they were
born in the same Village she could be a
Victoria Secret model you could look
like you know Shrek and it's just like
well we were the same age I had a good
job it worked our parents liked each
other now you really have to work you
really have to be the guy in it and so I
I would I would definitely kind of
that's what I want to add that like it's
not all bad in it and it's just another
stat to kind of give you some
perspective women modern women find 80
percent of men as unattractive and so on
dating apps which people will argue that
maybe people on dating apps aren't
looking for something serious but that's
the number one way people meet women
only swipe right five percent of the
time up to 20 on the high end in certain
studies so women are all sleeping with
the same guys so for guys that are in
that percentage it's like they just have
an abundance of girls throwing
themselves at them and then the women
will come back later and say men are
trashed up but that's who who we need to
have a speed dating thing me and you go
yeah I have we need to set up a speed
dating or even a quoting thing when we
show them how to do it properly and give
them questions to ask you know speed
dating but we provide the questions
you're helping me open wife school right
yes they turn modern women into wives we
need to try we need to do it what we
need to do we don't want to be saved no
they do I think some do you know what
right I want one more thing but I think
they do they want to they want to have
their fun and you know what stop it Alex
don't say that like oh
is right I'm not saying that is wrong
but why does it always boil down to
women
okay no don't say no because you see
what Nathan said I like you Nathan by
the way I appreciate girl but what made
me feel like you're not scared you're
more like scared to be stuck in one
because there's so many options out
there because you keep dipping your
cookie into the jars different jars of
different sauces so but here's here's
the reason so I think sorry the reason
why you don't want to come in I feel
like the way you explain to me to one
jar is because you're my ah because you
saw the other jar you saw the other day
you're like it might taste you said too
many options that's what you said
earlier
let me explain it to you so women leave
women divorced men 70 to 80 percent of
the time I I would argue in
relationships it's probably similar men
aren't leaving women as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible